Do you believe in Allah in Christianity?
>> Do I believe what in Christianity? I
couldn't hear the first part.
>> In Allah.
>> The if you mean Allah as a term of the
true God, then I can use the term Allah
for the true God of the Bible. But the
God of the Bible is not the God of the
Quran.
>> Okay?
>> They're not the same God because there
are contradictions between what the
Quran says about Allah and what the
Bible says about Allah. For instance, in
the [clears throat] Quran, all you are
is a slave and Allah is your Lord, but
you cannot be a son or daughter of
Allah. You know this, right? Or no? Do I
need to?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because I remember in a
Quran it says it is not appropriate for
the most merciful to take a son.
>> And yet the Bible, both the Old
Testament of the Jews and the New
Testament of Christians says God is a
father to believers.
>> Do you want me to show you those verses?
>> If you want. I It's up to you because I
You're asking me. Allah, the term Allah
is Arabic. There are Arabic Christians,
Arabic Jews. They use Allah. It's in the
Arabic Bible. But Allah of the Bible is
described differently from all of the
Quran. So if you want me to show you
where?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Let me show you here.
>> When you man's been like avoiding you,
dodging you. How though?
>> Because he's been invited to come and
debate on neutral platforms. And he
invited a friend of ours, Avery, to go
to the mosque. Avery went yesterday to
the
>> God Logic. Yeah, I spoke to him before.
>> What?
>> Yeah, I spoke to God Logic before. That
guy.
>> God Logic is my friend. Of course.
>> Yeah, I spoke to him before.
>> Yes, he's a good man. He's one of the
best. May the Lord preserve him and all
of us. But here, I want to show you
again.
>> The Old Testament, the what they call
the Tanakh, the Jews read it. It's not
just us. New Testament, we Christians
also read that. The Jews that don't
believe Jesus reject it. But I want you
to see how both of these books confirm
God is a father,
right? He's not just your master. You're
not just his slave. Okay,
let me just show you.
So, how can it be the same God? It can't
be the same God.
>> Here it goes.
Here, Old Testament, Exodus 4:22-23.
Then you shall say to Pharaoh, thus says
Yahweh, Israel is my son, my firstborn.
This is Moses speaking. And God is
telling Moses to tell Pharaoh, "So I
said to you, let my son go
[clears throat]
that he may serve me. But you refuse to
let him go. Behold, I will kill your
son, your firstborn."
Deuteronomy 14:1. You are the sons of
Yahweh your God. [clears throat]
You shall not gash yourselves nor shave
your head forehead for the sake of the
dead. Here's another prophet. Isaiah
63:16.
For you are our father, though Abraham
does not know us and Israel does not
recognize us. You, oh Yahweh, are our
father, our redeemer from everlasting is
your name. Again, same prophet. Isaiah
64:8. But now, oh Yahweh, you are our
father. We are the clay and you our
potter and all of us are the work of
your hand. Now what does Jesus say? This
is now Jesus. Huh? Matthew 5:9. Blessed
are the peacemakers for they shall be
called sons of God.
>> Are you a son of God?
>> I don't believe I am.
>> Because you don't know Jesus. So if you
don't know Jesus, you can't be a son of
>> wait. You you do you believe Islam is
Antichrist?
>> Yes. That's according to him on the New
Testament. What is the Antichrist?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But um we believe in
Jesus. We love Jesus as well.
>> That means nothing because we're told
Satan will inspire people to present a
different Jesus from the real one.
That's what the Bible tells us. We were
already warned about Muhammad and Joseph
Smith because we are told they'll come
preaching another Jesus from the one we
preach. meaning I believe in Jesus. But
what is he?
>> You said you said about another Jesus.
You said
>> yes. Is your Jesus the son of God?
>> No. He's a prophet.
>> Then that's not the same Jesus. What are
you not getting?
>> Is your Jesus came down from heaven as
the word of God who's the son of God to
become flesh?
>> No.
>> Then it's not the same Jesus.
Is your Allah the father of Jesus?
>> No.
>> Then it's not the same Jesus. Here it
is. 1 John 2:22-23.
Who is the liar but the one who denies
that Jesus is the Christ? This is the
Antichrist. The one who denies the
father and the son.
>> Yeah, but how how can we be Antichrist
when we believe in Jesus.
>> It's front of your eyes. Read it. See,
you didn't even listen to the verse I
read because you're talking over me. Is
Allah the father?
>> No. Is Jesus the son?
>> No.
>> And it says you're an antichrist right
there in front of you.
It's in front of your eyes, but you're
too busy not listening.
Right there, you're told if God is not
the father, Jesus not the son, you are
antichrist.
>> So how can you have the true God when
you deny God as father and Jesus son?
You are an antichrist which you're a
prophet.
>> Yeah. Okay. Understand the point.
>> Yeah. And Jesus warned us about false
prophets like Muhammad because he said
here or he says it.
>> I have started to read the Bible though.
>> Keep reading.
Read Luke and John and learn about Jesus
here. Matthew 24:23 25. Then if anyone
says to you behold here's the Christ or
there he is do not believe him. or false
Christs and false prophets will arise
and will show great signs and wonders.
They'll even do miracles, but not from
God because Satan will empower them so
as to deceive, if possible, even the
elect. Behold, I've told you in advance.
So, we were already told there'll be
false prophets, false Christs. Yep. Wow.
So, we're not shocked that Muhammad
comes 600 years later claiming to be a
prophet, but then denies who the Jesus
of history is.
Well, this actually
>> you just questioned me completely.
>> Yes, you should because Mad is not the
only one who came and claimed to be a
prophet. Today in America, you have the
people called Mormons. Their prophet
Joseph Smith.
>> Have you heard of them?
>> Mormons.
>> Yeah, Mormons.
>> Yeah, I've heard of them.
>> Jesus Christ Latter- Day Saints. They
say God appeared to Joseph Smith in the
1800s. He saw the angel Moroni revealed
to him golden plates which he then
translated which is the Book of Mormon a
revelation and that he actually saw God
the Father and Jesus Christ and he is a
prophet and those who came after him are
prophets. So here's another false
prophet who claims to believe in Jesus
but his Jesus is different.
>> Yeah, you understand your point.
[clears throat and cough] This
>> So which Jesus are you going to follow?
You want to follow G Muhammad Jesus? Why
not follow the Mormon Jesus or the
Jehovah Witness Jesus?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like No, just that
verse still shocked me cuz this is now
just questioning my fate.
>> Oh, this one's going to shock yours. You
ready?
>> Sure.
>> Because your prophet said an angel came
to him, right?
>> No, because like when I think about it
cuz then I see like Quran scientific
miracles and I think of how would they
have known that and that stuff. Who lied
to you, man? The Quran is errors. They
lied to you because
>> I've read the Quran. I was like
thinking,
>> huh,
>> brother, let me tell you why. You read
what they told you the Arabic means by
misinterpreting it. But you've never
looked at the Arabic or the or the
responses. The Quran is full of
scientific mistakes. I can show you that
they lied to you about oh the embryo
four stages. Yeah. Even the expansion of
the universe
>> and that was already in the Bible.
>> Is it 44:24? It says the universe is
expanding. Nothing you quote in the
Quran wasn't already known in previous
sources among the Greeks and the
Christians and the Jews.
>> What about the embology and that stuff?
>> That was taken from Gallen Greek
physician that the Christians were
studying and had translated in Arabic
which Muhammad get access to. Buddy,
>> I believe there's [snorts] any
contradiction in the Quran.
>> There's full of them. You want me to
show you some?
>> Yeah, because I remember in the Quran it
says, "If this book is other from your
Lord, you find
>> You sure you want me to go there?"
>> Sure.
>> Okay. It's up to you, my friend. We've
already over
>> because I want to know the truth.
>> All right. I'm going to show you, too,
but I'm going to show you some. But
right now, I'm going to show you a list
that we already documented. We've
already present over 100 contradictions
in the Quran and we respond to the
Muslims who try to then defend them
because they say the Bible is full of
contradictions. We try to explain
they're not, but we then return the
favor. Here it is. I'll get you the
link, but we'll go through some.
>> All right, hold on. Let me just show
you. I want large screen for everyone.
So, here's a list that you'll go
through, but I'll go through some with
you now.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Look how many we got here.
>> Okay. Oh, boy. We found over a hundred.
and counting. Damn, Gina.
>> But wasn't a contradiction in the Bible
as well?
>> Well, hold on. Even if there's
contradicting the Bible, that's not the
standard for the Bible. The Bible didn't
say if you find many contradictions in
it, then it's not from God. That's not
the test for the Bible. That's a test
for the Quran. And the Quran fails its
own test.
>> Okay. Um, yeah.
>> Let me show you just some, but I'm going
to go on in specific detail.
All right. I'm going to go one in
specific detail.
I don't know which one to start with you
because this is a list of them, but I
don't know if I want to even go here.
I'll probably go to the one I like.
There's a lot of them, but nonetheless,
this is just couple of them.
We have over a hundred, but yeah, I
don't know if I want to go there. Let me
go to the one that I I want you to try
to explain to me.
Chapter 229. He it is who created for
you all that is in the earth. Then then
turned he to the heaven and the word in
the context means he did the earth and
then he turned to the heaven
>> and fashioned into seven heavens. He is
the nor of all things. So I want you to
follow the sequence because then I I can
give you the commentators to show that
whoever tells you then is not sequential
they're lying to you. But nonetheless
then turned he to the heaven fashion in
the seven heavens. He is nor of all
things. So notice first what did he
create first?
>> Um he it is who created for you all that
is in the earth and he then turned he to
the heaven and fashion it as seven
heavens.
>> So what came first things?
Sorry.
>> What came first heaven or earth?
>> Uh earth.
>> Okay. Now, can you show me one scientist
that thinks the earth existed when there
was no heaven? So, where did the earth
exist?
>> One scientist. What?
>> Can you show me one scientist? Because
you appeal to scientific accuracy of the
Quran. Can you show me one scientist
that says there was an earth before
there was any heaven? Because the earth
is in the heavens in the universe.
>> How can you have the earth before there
was the universe? Because the seven
heavens includes the universe.
>> But it's going to get worse. Count the
days though. Lo, your Lord is Allah who
created the heavens and the earth in six
days. So six days, right?
>> Yes.
>> Then mounted he the throne. He
coverereth the night with the day which
is in haste to follow it. And hath made
the sun and moon and the stars
subservient by his command. His verily
is all creation and commandment. Blessed
be Allah the Lord of the worlds. Now
watch this one. This one. Now remember
that said six days. But pay attention to
the order. Say,
"Disbelieve ye verily in him who created
the earth in how many days?"
>> Two days.
>> Okay, count for me. All right, because
I'm not that good at math.
>> Yes, sir.
>> And ascribed ye unto him rivals, he and
none else is the Lord of the worlds. He
placed therein firm hills rising above
it, and blessed it, and measured therein
its sustenance in four days. So now
count for me. How many days did he take
to create the earth?
>> Two. How many days to create its
sustenance such as the hills?
>> How many?
>> Four.
>> 2 plus four is what?
>> Six.
>> Okay. Then
turned he to the heaven when it was
smoke. Now I got to ask you a question.
How the hell could the heaven be smoke
if the earth is already created?
>> Can I actually do research on that for
one one minute?
>> What?
>> I actually have no idea.
You cannot have a heaven that is smoke
when the earth is created because
where's the earth? It's in the heaven,
the universe.
So here your Quran says
>> I need to do research on this.
>> No, you can do it then. You can try to
say the answers. They'll be lying to you
because I've got the commentators. But
before we go there, I want you to follow
the logic here. Earth created two days.
That's nourishment four days when the
heaven was still smoke. No scientist
believes this. So if you're pling to
science,
the earth is in the heavens. It's in the
universe. The heaven must have already
been existing for the earth to be
fashioned. But here it says the heaven
was still smoke when he created the
earth and its nourishments. But now
catch it though. And he said unto it and
unto the earth. See the earth is already
existing
>> even when smoke, right?
>> Yeah.
How can you have the earth existing with
heaven as smoke? Where is it existing?
It has to be in the heaven. Now let's
see what the heaven is though before you
think you know. And ascribe ye unto him
rivals. Now watch your 11 again. He then
says come both of you. So if you still
doubt that he's talking to the earth
that's already created and the heaven
that smoke. He says come both of you
willingly or loth. They said we come
obedient.
Then he ordained them seven heavens and
two days and inspired in each heaven its
mandate. We decked the nether. Now the
nether means here let me show it to you.
So he determined seven days and two days
revealed its commandments in every
heaven.
>> Okay. We decked the nether meaning lower
heaven lamps.
>> Now this means he's talking about the
universe because the lamps would be the
stars, right?
>> Yeah.
>> How can you have the earth existing when
there's no universe? Because the earth
is in the universe.
>> Yeah, maybe you should ask that
question. O man.
>> Oh, I'd love to if he showed up, but he
runs. But coming back to you, do the
math again cuz let's count because
you're smart. It says here in 49, how
many days it took him to create the
earth?
>> Two. Two.
>> How many days did it take for him to
create his nourishment?
>> Four.
>> Two plus four is what? Six, right?
>> Yes. But then he took the heaven when it
was smoke. How many days did he it take
him to make it into seven heaven?
>> Two.
>> But now that's eight days. Two days to
create heaven from smoke into something.
>> Four days to create the earth's
nourishment. That's 2 and 46. But the
two days that it took to create the
earth, that's eight days.
I'll I'll be on this.